welcome back to New Rockstars it's me Mt
and Captain America New World Order will
feature Tim Blake Nelson's the leader as
the high flying Captain America's Main
antagonist as revealed by Papa Kevin
feige and his amazing friends and
Marvel's d23 conference and if the
leader is anything like he is in the
comics this means our favorite Uncle Sam
is gonna have to work for it in this
movie because I don't know if you know
about this but uh the leader can
freaking see the future with his
overgrown Dome that could reach the
ozone but what exactly is this new world
order that the leader will be affiliated
with anyway and who is behind it and
what are their goals and who are their
daddies and what do they do let's find
out together my nerd babies but first do
not forget to hit up new
rockstarsmerch.com so you can pick up
our newest latest Obsession shirts
inspired by both She-Hulk and House of
the Dragon they are only around for a
limited amount of time so buy it today
so you can have it tomorrow and for the
rest of your life so you can pass it
down to your children alright so with
the title like New World Order many
would assume that Sam Wilson is about to
battle some wild conspiracy theories on
the truth social app not true because I
have a feeling that the Captain America
4 prequel series Falcon and the Winter
Soldier made its first steps of
introducing Marvel's new world order via
the introduction of one Contessa
Valentina Allegra de Fontaine a
mysterious Madam that I believe will
actually be the head of hydra's New
World Order organization an organization
of secret super villains that have a
very small history in the comics
introduced in The Incredible Hulk
numbers 403 and 404 the new world order
was assembled by none other than the Red
Skull specific typically to act as he
puts it a super villain equivalent to
the United Nations because instead of
being evil independently Red Skull
assembled a group of high influence in
high-powered villains to coordinate
their efforts to take over the world but
unfortunately the Marvel Comics
purposely chose to keep most of the red
skulls new world order friends a secret
but we do know that the Spider-Man
villain the old cyborg silvermane was a
part of the red skull's Inner Circle and
that the Red Skull silvermane and seven
of their secret soulmates Enlisted the
help of other villains like the
Unstoppable Juggernaut the Mind
controlling mutant mentalo and the
leader's crazy ass gamma-powered
scientist brother madman to further
their world conquering agenda but though
the red skulls incarnation of the New
World Order only really lasted two
issues one of the few achievements that
that group had was the successful mind
control of the Incredible Hulk in his
smart Hulk form using their Hulk puppet
to battle The Avengers alongside their
henchmen the Juggernaut and while Marvel
Comics haven't officially revealed the
secret members of the world order except
for silvermane they did leave some hints
of who could have been in this Inner
Circle through the ungodly Frankenstein
ass experiment that the New World Order
science division were conducting in
their secret underground laboratory the
scientific monstrosity created by madman
known as piecemeal who appears to be an
abomination of a man with various body
parts of the members of the New World
Order with the head of the Red Skull the
arms of silvermain and what appears to
be the right leg of abomination the
Torso of the Atlantean villain atuma who
were getting into wakanda forever in the
hands of the mutant Sabertooth who
should now exist in the MCU if Wolverine
is Canon as of She-Hulk so all of these
villains could have thrown a piece of
their abilities together to develop this
weird looking monster but this all being
said and knowing that Hydra has had a
Whole Decade in the MCU to continue
their rebuilding efforts since we last
saw them in the first Ant-Man film with
Mitchell Carson I have a feeling that
Contessa Valentina Allegra de Fontaine a
character who has led Hydra before or in
the comics we'll be taking up the role
of the Red Skull in this new world order
that Captain America will have to face
in Captain America 4. using her science
division of nerds called the
Intelligentsia headed by the leader and
his insane ability to predict the future
to assemble her new world order team and
move hydra's chess pieces to put the
entire world in Checkmate because the
last time we saw the leader in MCU
Cannon was in the pages of the Avengers
Prelude comic when he was arrested by a
black widow right after he made the
Abomination after trying to get black
widow to collect Bruce Banner's blood so
that they could build an illustrious
future defined by power and influence
that he foresaw in his giant Cranium and
brought directly into Hydra custody
under the guise of Shield this future
that the leader foresaw was Marvel
Studios teasing Captain America 4 all
the way back in 2012 the year where
everybody except for John Cusack and his
family were supposed to die and like I
brought up in the channel before the
Intelligentsia already exists in the
background of the MCU and first appeared
in Avengers Age of Ultron with the
Avengers we're digging through hydra's
old Shield files looking for information
on Ulysses claw who apparently was a
former member of this group of Evil
Geniuses who won the comics consisted of
the leader Elias Starr AKA Egghead who
we saw in Ant-Man the WASP modak who
were getting in the 30 Hitman movie The
Mad thinker Red Ghost the Trapster and
Doctor Doom and together with their
brain power they were able to do
seemingly impossible things like break
into the Super secure kingdoms of both
wakanda and Atlantis for their own ends
and with Marvel projects like wakanda
forever set to introduce the villain
atuma Hawkeye reintroducing Kingpin and
She-Hulk reintroducing and freeing the
Abomination and potentially dating the
New World Order scientist madman under
the guise of Todd I think Val and the
leaders Intelligentsia are slowly
Gathering their new world order Inner
Circle by carefully manipulating world
events in the shadows to assemble the
Earth's evilest villains together to
coordinate their efforts and not fight
amongst each other for power that way
Hydra and their new world order can do
what best in the best way possible
orchestrate enough chaos in the world so
that the world willingly gives up their
freedom to Hydra to make them feel safe
a mission that Zola tells Steve and
Natasha blatantly in Captain America the
Winter Soldier Hydra created a word so
chaotic that humanity is finally ready
to sacrifice its freedom to gain its
security
once purification process is complete
hydra's New World Order will arise and
that is the New World Order in a
nutshell thank you guys so much for
watching this video you can follow me at
mastertami if you want to see me tweet
some weird [ __ ] and really fun theories
but more importantly you can fall into
rockstars wherever we are on the
internet and hey do not forget don't
forget it you gotta go to New
rockstarbush.com You Gotta Buy our
shirts man She-Hulk and House of the
Dragon they're amazing shirts buy them
because they're not gonna last forever
but yes thank you guys so much for
watching I love you guys so much and
I'll see you guys next time bye
[Music]